could i do to destroy my business that  if i did this it would all stop for  example if i stopped creating free  content that was better than everyone  else in the marketplace i would  eventually stop getting new customers if  i hired a team of people that were not  good then i would lose my reputation if  i select customers that are not going to  be likely to be successful then i'm not  going to create the client outcomes and  my reputation will suffer as a result  these anchors will change over time but  the easiest way to discover them is not  to think what should i do to be  successful but how few things that have  the biggest leverage could i do to  destroy my business reverse those and  you'll find your competitive advantage